desde Cuba Pablo Beltrán máximo líder de
la guerrilla colombiana del Ln tiene
optimismo ante las negociaciones de paz
propuestas por el gobierno del
presidente Gustavo Petro Beltrán asegura
que solo es cuestión de semanas para que
representantes de la organización armada
y del gobierno reinicien el proceso de
paz en Colombia el año pasado hubo lo
que se llamó al estallido social tres
meses de protestas en las calles el
gobierno que llegó el de Petro llega
acogiendo parte de ese mandato Esperamos
que lo cumpla y nosotros como Ln también
nos sentimos responsables de cumplir con
ese mandato de que haya cambios en
Colombia entre ellos que haya paz por
parte del gobierno la intención de
negociar es Clara desde antes de su
llegada a la casa de nariño Gustavo
Petro ya hablaba de la necesidad de una
paz Total que termine con el último
conflicto armado interno del continente
americano una propuesta que podría
evitar el acuerdo de paz pactado con la
extinta guerrilla de las FARC firmado en
2016 sin embargo para Pablo Beltrán El
ejemplo del proceso con las Farc le
genera más incertidumbre que confianza
La FARC entregó las armas y comenzaron a
matarlos
van más de 360 es guerrillero firmantes
de esos acuerdos que han matado ahora
los primeros niveles de confianza es
acuerdo que se haga acuerdo que se
cumple así se construye la confianza
pero cumplen ambos porque la Far cumplió
y el estado no el último intento de
negociaciones entre el estado colombiano
y el grupo armado ilegal Se frustró
luego de que el gobierno del ex
presidente Iván Duque decidiera
suspender las conversaciones en 2019
tras el atentado contra una escuela de
Cadetes de la policía en Bogotá que dejó
22 muertos